and then you got people
that just want to like you know promote
the [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
like this dude charleston white i seen
this stupid [ __ ]
like honestly i've seen a couple of his
videos you know what i'm saying he
like like but he says some [ __ ] and he
kept on talking [ __ ] about the asian
people talking about us like we dogs and
[ __ ] like that talking about us
crazy and i seen him talk about other
things
crazy too like he talked about ex he
just he's the type of [ __ ] that
just is that that old head that's always
online just running his mouth
yeah okay yeah i see yeah okay this bozo
you know what i'm saying he just want to
take something
that's hot and want to like like you
know what i mean more gas on like like
pour
gas on it but he want to spin it his way
so he could like get clout
and get people to listen to him and then
and then he'll
spin it a certain way and then yeah i'm
saying like he
he he the type of [ __ ] that's
gonna get like you know
he's not he's no good bro he's the type
of [ __ ] that you start listening
to you
he he'll start putting dumb [ __ ] in your
head you know what i'm saying
like and and all of this [ __ ] he says is
crazy yeah i'm saying but
certain [ __ ] he's saying like you know
he was talking about johnny dang right
and then he was just so i i hate asian
[ __ ]
every asian [ __ ] need the
[ __ ] die i don't give a [ __ ] i
spit on the asians
man that's crazy
man and i saw that [ __ ] and that's just
ignorant like
that's just that's super [ __ ] racist
i would punch that [ __ ] in the
mouth i wouldn't give a [ __ ] if he got
20
100 people with him man i'll punch him
writing this [ __ ] and we just gonna have
to get it we just don't have to get it
with 100 [ __ ] bro
[ __ ] you mean bro you face your mouth to
say some dumb [ __ ] like that bro
like imagine if somebody else said some
[ __ ] like that to to another race like
to the
that'd be crazy you know what i'm saying
i would never fix my mouth to say no
dumb [ __ ] like that to anybody you feel
me that's cool but this stupid
[ __ ] out here
promoting that [ __ ] like how has he not
been banned
on instagram or twitter there's a lot of
stupid [ __ ] out here man
[ __ ] like that [ __ ] bro
[ __ ] like you know i'm saying
that's that's
hate speech bro fax that's hate speech
facts that shouldn't make me like that
should make me upset bro
you know what i'm saying that should
make me upset